who was sent.
>> So you still don't know what the angel
is.
>> Okay, I told you already. The angel is a
revelation or what is that? What is
that? Beginning we don't need to know
beyond that.
>> We don't need to know.
We don't need to know beyond
[Music]
the
>> Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John can't be
the jail because Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John were written decades after
Jesus. Okay. Or a century. My question
is when was Okay. When was when was the
angel written?
>> In the time No, it wasn't written in the
time of Jesus.
>> We don't say that.
>> When was it? I didn't ask that. When was
it written?
>> Is the angel a revelation?
>> Yes. When was it written?
>> Okay. Whom was it revealed to?
>> When was it revealed? My question. Okay.
You know what? I'll do you another
favor. I'll answer again. So, it's so
yes, it's a revelation. Who was it
revealed to? Jesus. According to the
Quran.
>> Okay. What language? Now, hold on. No,
this is my question. No, no, no, no.
This is my question. language wasn't
revealed.
>> This is my question.
>> Language wasn't revealed. This is my
question. So, he goes based on the
Quran. Now, what's the question? The
question is when was the angel written?
>> Much later after Jesus asked when
>> I don't know exact date.
>> Oh, okay. Good. All right. Good. So, you
don't know these.
>> Answer the question. Bible.
>> Wait. Let me let me let me No, no one at
a time. I know.
>> I've answered your question. Now, let me
ask you. Let me let me Now, let me ask
No, no. I don't want you to let me make
this point.
>> What was the language of the revelation?
Maybe we should do one. What was the
language of the revelation of Jesus?
>> Okay. So now, so now I'm gonna respond
and say what I'm saying.
>> So you're not going to answer my
question.
>> Well, I am just going to say, ladies and
gentlemen, notice what you're running
from. Notice what you're running from
the question.
>> Notice what you're running from.
>> What language was the angel revealed in?
>> Okay, good. Go.
>> All right. Thank you. So So nowang. So
guys, this is where we're at. Hold on a
second. This is where we're at. Notice
how they're running from this. So he's
already So notice, guys, notice the
interruption. You're already in panic
mode. You're the one panic mode.
>> It's really cute. I It's really cute.
They're interrupting it every time. When
you got to interrupt your opponent, it
shows you have a weak position. You're
so weak. This is a weak position.
>> Ask me a question. I answered it. It's
my turn to ask.
>> Can I speak my turn to ask?
>> No, it's not. It's not what it was. Let
me speak, please.
>> He asked me a question. I answer now. It
is my
>> Let me speak, please. So, answer the
question.
>> All right. Thank you for letting me
speak. I'll let I'm going to speak now.
So, this is why he didn't want me to say
this point. He said that the that
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John can't be
the angel because the angel was written
decades and centuries after Jesus
ascended. So, however, guess what? But
guess what? He believes the same thing
about the angel.
>> Oh,
oh, oh. So, so here we are. Hold on. Let
me finish. I'm about to see the
>> I know you don't. Hey, hey, I know.
Look, it's like this. You know, sometime
sometimes Michael Jordan is about to
bust a move before you can see it
coming. Okay.
>> So, you can't see the move coming right
now. Now, he's playing. So, this is what
it is. Now, it's
>> So, this is what it is. Stop
interrupting me. Stop interrupting me.
You already did that. You already did
that. You already answer my question.
You already did that. So, I'm landing my
point.
>> I'm landing my point.
>> How long? How long did it take? Give me
30 seconds.
Okay. There it is.
>> Chill out. Chill out.
>> So, notice the hypocrisy. The hypocrisy
is he doesn't know when the engine was
written. Oh, he don't need to now. Now
it don't matter. Yeah. Yeah. But we need
to know though. We need to know. So look
look look. So look look here it is.
Look. He doesn't know when the was
written. So therefore it could have been
like what he's claiming written
centuries or decades after. So it
doesn't disqualify Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John from being the so that is out.
So now let's talk about the language.
What language was the angel written in?
This is a this is this is actually a
good question. What I say to this is
Watch this.
>> Wait a minute.
[Music]
What's the What's the What's the What's
the What's the What's the What's the
the What's the
We have this showmanship. You know,
honestly, I thought he was someone who
sincere to have a debate here. He turned
out into a showmanship and he started
like
you know when he says Allah it is the
remember that
the
know the hour
came to me on the
Now, Now watch this guys. Watch this.
>> He says that we don't have any early
manuscripts of the angio or of of
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John, right? We
don't have that. No, no, no, no.
>> We have no manuscripts from the first
100 years.
>> So from the first 100 years, but all all
I need I got you. All I need besides a
beat that's super dumping is a
manuscript from the seventh century
because Muhammad says that the Injil is
with them. It's with the Christians. So
all I need is something from the seventh
century. Luckily, glory be to Yahweh
specifically, we got second century
manuscripts. We got third century
manuscripts, fourth, fifth, 6th, 7th,
8th, 9th, 10th, 11. We got it all. So
basically, I don't need a first century
manuscript. All I need is what Muhammad
said is with him in the seventh century.
So my question is this. How do you know
since you don't know when the was
written and it it looks the language?
Hold on. It's It looks like you
language. Do Do you know the language?
>> I don't need I have the Quran. Why
should I need the Bible? I don't need
the Bible. The Bible is not standard.
You spoke enough. Can I speak now?
>> What? What language?
>> Can I respond to what I language? Yeah,
I will respond to what he just said. So,
he doesn't know the language.
>> What language is the interrupting? I
know you're panicking. That's the
question. I know when you when you face
the master chef already interrupted the
chef panics.
>> He was already interrupted. My shoe
chef, he was already interrupting.
>> Okay. So my shoe chef, yeah,
>> what I'm saying is this. If if he
doesn't know the language of the of the
angel, what it was revealed in. Okay.
First and foremost, the true message of
Jesus is lost.
>> Okay. He says we don't have it. We don't
need it because the Quran al
mean it is something Yes. A guardian of
what? Of from the previous scriptures.
And the truth
>> to the Quran. And the Quran is the one
which will distinguish the truth of the
previous scriptures from the falsehood
that have been in incorporated in the
Bible testament. So clearly we have al-
mu which is Quran all we need my friends
we don't need anything like you know
what because there's a hadith of the
prophet peace and blessings be upon him
he said that by I swear by it says even
if Moses was here in my time he will
have no choice but to follow me that
means to follow the Quran and the sunnah
so even if Moses who knew the Torah did
he know the Torah it was revealed to him
so the prophet peace be upon him already
answers was there their kind of problems
or whatever they have clearly that Mus
Alisam if he was in my time and this is
from Mustad Ahmed you can go and check
it if Mus Alam was here even he will
have no choice but to follow me now this
clearly nips it in the butt again so
like you correctly said you have nothing
from the first century imagine today you
are hearing this topic here and after
100 years nobody will record it all of
the recording disappears and then
someone comes in the second century you
have a small credit card statement of
what was Then you have a few more books
in the fourth century that we will
accept.
>> You're destroying Muhammad. I don't need
to because Muhammad peace be upon him
says the Quran he to him was revealed
the Quran is.
>> Nice.
>> Yes.
>> So we have the original Quran.
Alhamdulillah in Arabic.
>> We have even the first century alijra
manuscripts of the Quran.
>> We have a lot of evidence prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him for the
Torah. They have nothing for 1200.
>> Nothing for 1200 years.
>> Nothing from the Bible. Like I said only
fragments. They say less than less than
maybe even the for the first thousand
years they have less than 500
manuscripts. Most of them are after the
first first millennia. Okay.
>> Okay. Go on.
>> All right. Beautiful. So uh guys let's
um let's all say a prayer
>> forb because let's pray let's pray a
prayer to our Lord Jesus Christ
>> to have mercy on who they believe is a
prophet Muhammad because he just threw
him under the bus and buried him.
>> Let me tell you how he did it. I'll tell
you'all how he did it. What he did was
he said, "We don't have nothing of the
gospel. There was nothing in the first
century." And so there's nothing that
exists way until later. But
unfortunately in the seventh century,
Muhammad says that they have it. He says
that he's confirming what is with them
into whom? What is with them? And a
matter of fact, it gets even better.
Muhammad says that we can find his
description written in the Torah and the
angel with them. But according to
Hashem, Muhammad's a liar. Allah doesn't
know what he's talking about. They don't
actually have the gospel. They actually
don't have the Torah. They don't have
the revelation because what they have is
not from the first century.
>> Okay?
>> So, look, I'm not yet.
>> I'm going to stick with what Allah tells
me. If Allah says I'm good with seventh
century manuscripts, that's all I need.
That's that's all I need. So he follows
the law.
>> I don't need first
that way. Guys, he don't know what
you're talking about.
>> Oh, by the way, have you finished yet?
>> Do you hear me talking?
>> Yeah, I do. Okay. Relax.
>> What are you going to stop?
>> I'll let I'll stop. But hey, are you
even longer than I did, dude?
>> No. No. I had 2 minutes.
>> No,
watch it.
>> Hash, I I didn't complain when you
really long. No, it's not 30 seconds. 30
seconds. No, it's not 30 seconds. It's
going to be it's going to be when I
finish speaking. That's what I'm saying.
So, I'll do the same.
>> You already did that.
>> Watch.
>> You already went for like 4 minutes,
bro.
>> No, no, no. I will do the You're in
panic mode, bro. Relax.
>> Relax.
All right. So, guys, it's it's okay,
guys. It's okay. So, this is where we're
at. Okay. So, they had the NIL with them
in the seventh century. I don't need
first, second, third, fourth, fifth, or
sixth. I need seventh century
manuscripts. Luckily, we have before.
Okay. They have the angel with them. Now
he said that I don't know the language
that the angel was written in. I said
alahuam right now I'm an original Quran
only Christian. I believe in the
original Quran before it got corrupted.
So what we're asking is when I I know
you don't know what that is. So I don't
know where you're going with that.
>> Hey look look us up. It's okay. So when
we're talking about what the angel is
I'm I'm talking directly to you. Notice
how I'm talking directly to you. Stop. I
asked you what language was the in jail
written in and you didn't give an answer
to that. Oh, but do you? So, here's
this.
>> Hey, I want you to tell us what language
was the in jail written in.
>> You have the mic.
>> Okay,
>> you going with your notes?
>> When he when he actually says,
>> it's okay. We all use notes.
>> This is something that the Quran is
confirming.
>> The Quran confirms as a revelation. We
have already
>> Is it with them?
>> Folks, stop interrupting. interrupt me.
I know you're panicking. Calm down. Is
it with them? Calm down.
>> Is it with them?
>> Calm down, dear.
>> So when I'm speaking, you be quiet and
then
>> But you wasn't quiet when I'm speaking.
>> Yeah. So now what are you doing?
>> So I'm doing what you did.
>> No, I said you when you misrepresent me,
then I I'll
>> Is it with them or not? Just yes or no?
>> Yes. I'm
>> Okay. He said yes.
>> I will answer the way I want. Okay.
>> I said they don't have nothing from the
first century. What did this liar say?
They don't have it at all.
>> That's what you said.
>> Watch. No. Go and watch the video. I
said they have nothing.
>> You said that we don't have it. You said
we don't have enough protecting me.
>> But you're lying.
>> You're panicking.
>> You're lying.
>> You're panicking. So this is what I
said. I said from the first century they
have nothing. And he agreed with me. He
concealed that point.
>> Now you're lying again because they said
he said from the second, third, fourth,
fifth. What do they have? They only have
500 manuscripts from the first
millennia. I'm giving you 1,000 years.
>> Oh, so we have the
>> 1,000 years.
>> Okay. We have the stop.
>> We have 500 manuscripts of the NG. Nice.
>> 500 manuscript. Okay. Not thousand. Stop
lying. of the of the NGO, right?
>> Okay. Are you going to keep
interropping?
>> Sorry. Sorry. Go ahead.
>> At least respect his age. You know, he's
twice older than
>> Yeah. Yeah. You're right. You're right.
Right. He's my He's my elder.
>> He's my elder. He's trying to jump out
the pot. I'm trying to keep him in
there.
>> I said clearly that for the first 100
years, they have nothing. You already
conceded to that. So, I don't need to
argue that the point. Yes, you did. You
don't. You said second, third, fourth.
You never mentioned the first.
>> Yeah, you're right. First century.
>> So, first century. By the way, he says
from the seventh century, he has
something. So, now you're saying there's
a gap of 700 years. And he's not going
to believe any of them. He's only going
to believe what Muhammad says. Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him or the Quran,
if you're referring to the Quran, it
talks about the general confirmation,
not the whole book is a confirmation.
Because when Jesus said Jesus said the
same thing about the Pharisees that do
not do as they do, but listen to what
they say and follow that. So follow the
teachings. Does it mean that all the
teachings of the Pharisees you guys
follow? No, you don't. you follow the
general teaching of the Torah because if
you followed everything the Pharisees
the Pharisees even called Jesus as um as
a as a demonp possessed and as someone
who blasphemed God so if you're going to
consider the allegations of the Jews
upon Jesus then you'll have to believe
all that but I say the Quran is al
Muhammad we don't need the Bible we
don't even need to prove it to you
you're the one digging for it you know
why you come to the Muslims because you
realize that you guys don't have the the
gospels so you have no you have no
evidence So now you're coming to the
Muslims as there is a dilemma. We
Muslims for the past 1400 years not a
single Muslim said oh this is something
that we have a problem with. We don't
have a problem because I said there is a
clear hadith from the prophet peace and
blessings be upon him that even if Musa
Alisam you know that implies to Jesus as
well. So even when Jesus when he comes
in the second coming guess whom he's
going to follow according to Islamic
teaching which he's basing his argument
on according to the Islamic teaching
Jesus is going to follow the teaching of
rasool Allah peace and blessing be upon
him. Okay very clear now if you're going
to follow follow it fully and Jesus is
going to kill the dal and Jesus is going
to eventually die. If you believe your
god can die, then that is your god. He
is immortal, not immortal. And we know
that your teaching, you will, you know,
you will come with this dilemma, but
you'll never discuss the trinity. If you
have the guts, make that the next uh
debate after this. How about that?
>> Will you do that?
>> Yeah. Okay. All right. So, um, you said
a lot of things. I I'll try to work
backwards.
>> Yeah. At least I stop.
>> So, he quoted Well, you went a long
time. Very long. Very long. And I And I
did not complain about your time. Okay.
So, ladies and gentlemen, did you guys
hear him quote Jesus?
>> But I I thought we didn't have Jesus's
words.
>> So, he quotes Jesus. He quotes Matthew
23, but says that we don't have the
gospel,
>> bro. I don't know what we're talking
about. Are you okay, bro? Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa. Relax.
>> Leave the Bible.
>> Your panic. Your panic meter is going
up, up and up, up. All right, just bring
it back down. There we go. Logos.
>> Keep lying. logos.
>> Your your showmanship doesn't work with
>> logos.
Are you going to say like the Hindus
now?
>> There we go.
>> Listen, he goes los a big word. So guess
what? It's okay. Hashim, it's okay.
>> Hashim, it's okay, bro.
>> I know. It's okay. So So notice So
notice you're bigger. Step back. Step
back.
>> Okay. No problem.
>> Okay. So notice he quoted Jesus after
making a case that we don't have the
words of Jesus. I I know I I'm so
confused. No, no, that's not what you
said. You said cuz you said even Jesus
said you said even Jesus said that you
need to follow the follow what the
Pharisees say, not what they do. So now
I'm going to show you how you butcher
that and show you how it doesn't work.
Jesus said as they sit in the seat of
Moses, do what they say, not what they
do. That means they're teachers of the
law. So when they're teaching the law,
obey. When they go outside of that, you
don't got to do what they because
they're making up their own traditions.
Well, that's what it says. It says it
says seed of Moses. So you're lying. You
don't even know the word. You don't even
know that. You don't even know that. So
now So now are you going to keep
interrupting? You get But I stopped that
though. You're a hypocrite. You did that
first. You're a hypocrite. You did that
first.
>> I'm actually learning from you.
>> You did that first. Now you're a
hypocrite. So anyway, back to this. Back
to your Quran cuz you're trying to run
from your Quran according to your Quran.
Now you saidanguage, notice this says he
that the Quran gives a general
confirmation, right? It confirms that
know some of what is in not all of it.
Um I'm sorry. Let's quote Allah again.
Chapter 2 verse 85. Do you believe in
part of the scripture but reject the
rest?
>> Are you done?
>> Not yet.
>> Not yet. Hallelujah. So ladies and
gentlemen, this is what Hey, this is
what he wants us to believe.
>> This is all they can do.
>> This is what he wants us to believe. He
wants us to believe that Allah said,
"Don't reject part of the scripture and
then believe in other parts, but take it
all. Cuz if you do that, you're going to
go to hell." He wants us to believe that
Allah is doing exactly what he said not
to do.
>> Okay?
>> So when we talk to Muslims, I'm not
done, bro. You'll know when I'm done.
>> Yeah.
>> When we talk to Muslims, they tell us
one thing. Allah says the opposite. So
what you need to do is deal with this.
How are you talking about a general
confirmation when Allah says you got to
believe in all of the book not some of
it? Please direct that. Uh answer that
directly. 285.
>> Okay. Whom is he talking to in 285?
>> The Jews.
>> The Jews. Clearly that time they had the
Torah. This is the context of the Torah
when they had it not after the
revelation of the Quran. That's why in
if he read 275 and 279 then he would
know that Allah already declares it to
be corrupted. Very clear in the Quran.
Do you coveret the hope of believers
that they would believe for you while a
party of them used to hear the words of
Allah and then distort i.e the Torah
after they had understood it while they
were knowing. So Allah is telling you
they distort the words of the of the
Torah and this says the same thing in
279 as well. Okay. It says so woe to
those who write the scripture
>> with their own hands.
>> Yes. Where is my chamcha? I'll cook this
guy.
Okay. All right. So then they say, okay.
So woe to those who write the scripture
with their own hands. Then say this is
from Allah in order to exchange it for a
small price. Woe to them for those the
hands have written and woe to them for
they
for what they earn. Allah is clearly
telling you that these scriptures were
already corrupt. When does Allah say
this? When the prophet peace be upon him
was there. So in that time and that
shows the difference between the general
confirmation and confirming the entire
it never confirms the entire Torah or
the angel never does in the Quran. If
you can show me like the way he admitted
he doesn't have the original language
Allaham yeah not Jesus Jesus or Yahweh
Alam Allaham
>> he doesn't have the manuscript from the
first 100 years again Allaham. So what
he's depending on is not the original
language, the words of anonymous
authors. Because most Christian
scholars, they don't claim that Mark,
Matthew, Luke, and John wrote the Bible,
the gospel. They say it was written by
anonymous authors. And we can find many
Christian scholars, key Christian
scholars like Bruce Mezer, the teacher
of Bartman, who says that the Bible has
been corrupted. So he agrees with the
Quran unlike this uh you know guy who's
come here for a show with his little
spoon and his little cup like uh are you
looking for a job for a chef here?
>> I'm already a chef.
>> Exactly. That's why you're not an
author. Sorry. Not a
>> I'm already a chef.
>> He's not really someone who is an expert
in the Bible. He's a chef.
>> Do your work. Cook.
>> All right. Thank you. All right.
>> So to make my guys, did you guys hear
him
>> cooking a bad
>> No. Hey, no. Hey, I want y'all to pay
attention to his point, guys. It's
almost like he's never watched the video
before.
>> This he's so you're you're so behind
schedule. Well, you need to learn. This
is why cuz if if you would if you would
have watched Did I interrupt you? Did I
interrupt you? Did I interrupt you?
>> No, I did not. I let you go this whole
time. So ladies and gentlemen, he said
that when the Quran says that you are
not to believe in only part of the
scripture, oh that's only talking about
the Torah when they used to have it, not
in Muhammad's time. Uh-oh. In chapter
5:43 it says they have the Torah. Let's
quote it. It says, do you know your
Quran? You You hate your Quran. You
don't know your Quran. It says, this is
what it says. It says, "Why do they come
to you, oh prophet,
>> when they have the Torah
>> in which Allah's judgments are in?" So,
hey, if you want the context, I'll give
it to you, Sam. Here's the background.
The background is is that they went to
Muhammad for a judgment. People
committed adultery. They wanted a
ruling. They did not want to follow the
Torah. So, when they went to Muhammad,
let me finish. When they went to
Muhammad, they said, "Give us a ruling."
Guess what Muhammad said? Well, whatever
agrees with the Quran, that's what you
go with. No. He said, "Whatever aligns
with the Quran, that's what you use."
No. He said, "Bring the Torah."
>> Wait a second. According to Muhammad,
they had the Torah. According to Hashem,
they didn't have the Torah. Who should
we go with, Muhammad or Hashem?
>> Okay. Okay. We're going to go with
Muhammad. Okay. Hold on. Hey, I was They
had the Torah. Hashem says they didn't.
I guess Allah and Muhammad are liars.
Hashem is upon the hawk. It's okay. So
now this is where we're going to
continue because it's I mean you made
your burial. It's it's embarrassing.
Well, you did. You did. You made your
burial. Oh, it's okay. You can say I'm
deluded. So guess what? He went to 275.
>> That says that they have distorted it
after hearing it. Does that say that
they went and changed the book?
>> No. Because the Quran is actually
consistent with how they distort. 378
says they tongues not with their hand.
Now all right
279 if we talk about 279
>> very clear
>> wo to those who write the book with
their own it's cool when they do it
this is amazing
argument
come
>> shut up
>> so so this is where we're at he doesn't
know what the agil is he doesn't know
what language it was written he doesn't
know when it was written
Notice this. I say Allah. Maybe Allah
told him what what the language be.
Okay. So look at the vow this.
He says we don't need to know the
language. So what you asking me, bro?
You don't need to know.
Okay. So I need to respond.
>> So respond to this. What language? I
listen to you. I listen to you.
>> What language was he and Jill written
in? And you said that you said that the
gospel writers were anonymous. Okay,
tell me who wrote the jail. Make sure
they're not anonymous authors.
>> When was it written
>> and what is the principle in the Quran
in regards to picking and choosing what
you
>> Hey, hold this phone point.
>> Very good.
>> Very good. We need to know all this. He
is the one for him the Bible the gospels
are important because he follows their
injection. What do I follow? I follow
the Quran. The Quran is for me
injection. So these questions you know
the reason he's asking cuz he's
projecting it on me. He realizes he's
actually bankrupt about this knowledge.
Jesus did not give him. The Holy Spirit
did not give him. The Holy Spirit was
supposed to be guiding all the
Christians. None of them know the
language that Jesus preached him.
You don't know it
[Music]
the triune doctrine this dog of yours
because you didn't find it in the Bible.
>> Muslim
none of that is important. Now what you
what I was about to say is that when he
is at fidget and he did it on camera
that in chapter 2 verse 79 he talks
about the the Torah being corrupted the
words been corrupted. Paul said that I
didn't say that if you
say that because in 279 it clearly says
about them writing it with their own
hands and attributing it to God. The
Quran, if you understood 279, you would
say that because in 279, it clearly says
about them writing it with their own
hands and then attributing it to God for
a few pennies.
>> That wasn't the Quran. That was the
Torah.
>> Oh, how does it say that?
>> He's too ignorant. He's too ignorant
because he says, look at the context.
Very simple. Okay. What's
>> You said you're only going to interrupt.
>> Well, you're talking to me. You're a
hypocrite. No, I'm talking to them.
You're talking You don't even know when
I'm talking. You charge. Don't worry.
You're stopping a hypocrite. Now, what
I'm saying is very clear. Look, if for
them the Bible is important, go and find
your manuscripts, the missing
manuscripts. Why did it take you five
centuries to even uh to to canonize it?
They had to actually pick and choose the
correct gospels and they had maybe
hundreds and they discarded all the ones
which are false and they took four. So
for them to say that this is our book
and we actually take our injunctions
from it, it is something which is really
sad because they don't know the truth of
it. They're to rely on Greek manuscripts
written centuries after according to Dr.
Bartum and he says that majority of the
Bible manuscripts are from 9th century
and beyond. Okay, very clear. He's an
expert unlike you who is a chef. Okay,
so he knows more about the New
Testament. The New Testament scholars
know more about the New Testament than
the chef who only is good at cooking
whatever it is.
You going to eat me? You're animal
worse for him because he's And that's
exactly what the Christians do, don't
they? Eat the flesh, which is Jesus,
drink his blood like I wouldn't be
surprised if you are a caribel, too.
Okay. Now, this is exactly what we see
with regards to the Bible.
>> Biggest Muslim I've ever seen.
>> This is Yeah. You're getting cooked and
in fact, you're getting baked and
grilled. By the way, for us we like
grace during
Mubarak to all of you. Okay? And this we
follow the sunnah of whom? Ibraimam just
like just like Jesus followed the sunnah
of Ibraimisam and Jesus was circumcised
in the flesh unlike pro.
>> What does this got to do with this is
showing you the corruption of your book.
Most Christians here are uncircumcised
according to the Jesus.
>> What does this have to do with filthy
dogs? What are you honorable?
>> I'm about your your God Jesus. What are
you on about?
>> I'm on about your God Jesus who was set.
>> So you still don't know what the angel
is.
>> Okay, I told you already. The angel is a
revelation or what is that? What is
that? Beginning we don't need to know
beyond that.
>> We don't need to know.
>> We don't need to know beyond the Quran
is al Muhammad. The Quran is the one
which is al Muhammad. If something if
they say the Quran look we are not
saying all of the Bible is corrupted and
I never said this at any point. If you
listen to this video, not once did I say
that there are remnants of truth in
there like Deuteronomy 6:4 where he
talks about the weness of God not the
trinity like uh John uh sorry Mark 12:29
where Jesus confirmed the shama from
Deuteronomy. Is that correct? Okay. I
said not all of his corrupted part. So
when he talks about the oneness of God
when Jesus says in John 73 this is
eternal life that they may know you the
father the only true God the father.
Yeah. The father is a title given to God
Almighty because No, that's the God of
Jesus. Got you.
>> That is the God of Jesus. It's not
Allah.
>> We don't call the We don't call Allah
the father.
>> I know you don't.
>> This is a language I'm using from the
Bible, not from the Quran. Try to keep
up, chef. Trust me.
>> That's why you're not you keep digging
your grave even deeper.
>> No, I don't. Actually, I'm I'm grilling
you. You don't even realize it.
>> Okay. It is like putting a frog in in a
boiling water and really realize it's
going to be boiled alive, they won't
know. I respond.
>> Keep jumping here and there. Go on.
Respond.
>> Okay. All right. Everybody listen up.
Everybody listen up. Listen up. Listen
up. Listen up. Guys, listen up.
>> I mean, um, guys, I hope you guys wore
black.
>> This is tough. This is a sad day for
Hashem. Really? He's passed his talk.
No,
>> he's black because he's your all right.
Notice this, ladies and gentlemen.
>> That's why he's black.
>> When we ask what the is when we ask what
the is, notice the biggest copout in
Muslim history. it is. We don't need to
know what the is.
>> We don't.
>> We don't need to know. So, let me tell
you why it's important. Let me tell you
why it's important.
>> Let me tell you guys why this copout
just destroyed his position and all of
Islam together.
>> Because he's tell that we don't have it.
>> How can you tell us that we don't have
it when you don't know what the heck it
is?
>> That makes no sense. So look all all of
these all of these questions that I'm
asking you all of these details that I'm
asking you about the angil it will
distinguish what the angel is versus
from what I have this is how you'll be
able to know that what I have is not it.
So when I ask like for example who you
say we don't need to know that. So that
means you can't qualify Luke and John.
>> Okay. Hold on. Time out. When I when you
say when I ask was written you say we
don't need to know that. So then you
can't disqualify scriptures if they were
written a decade or even a century later
cuz you don't know.
>> Okay. So when you talk about the angio
and you don't even know the details of
it. You don't even know the language it
was written in. You don't know any of
this language. No, this is your this is
what you said. You said this. You agreed
with me. You said this. Yeah, I agree
that you don't know. I agree that you
don't know. So, Muslims, a matter of
fact, I'm going to talk to the Muslim
audience.
>> Okay. So, for the Muslims, stop saying
because you'll look as silly as this.
Because you don't if you if you don't
know what it is, stop telling me what
it's not. It's as simple as that. Now
going with the cor the the confirmation
topic. Oh yeah like it's okay. Go ahead
again
reality. I'm sure that's why the devil
fell the Satan. You know why? For
arrogance.
>> You know
>> just like the chef here.
>> It's okay guys. It's okay. This is very
important. We're getting n I mean it's
nipped in the bud right here. So now
about the confirmation of the
scriptures.
>> No language.
>> Now notice the notice the confirmation
of the scriptures. He says and he stood
he stood on it. He like double backed on
it. He said that you we only confirm
part of what you have.
>> Double back.
>> I mean I mean I mean I don't mean double
back like you back. I mean like you like
you doubled on it. Like you
>> What does double mean?
>> It means that you stood on it.
>> Oh, thank you. Which language is that?
>> Yeah. Sorry. You know,
>> definitely not American or English.
>> Yeah. Sorry. So I think he backed out on
it.
>> He he stood on it, right? He stood on
the fact Yeah. He stood firm. He
repeated it that you can you can you
have the ability as Muslims to pick and
choose what is true and what is false in
the Bible in the scriptures based on the
Quran because the Quran is a Mim right
Muhammad is a guardian and guess what
the Quran did a terrible job of guarding
the angel cuz we don't know what the
heck it is anymore
>> terrible terrible guardian now by the
way
>> guardian against the truth
>> oh now by the way for the truth now
watch this watch this if If he was if he
was correct, his Quran contradicts it
because the Quran says if you're in
doubt about what Allah has revealed,
talk about the Quran,
go back to the people who believe in the
Bible. So the judge, the criterion is
the Bible, not the Quran. So says it one
way, Hashem says another.
>> When you landed,
>> yeah, I'm about to land right here. I
just want to know when are you going to
get on Allah's side and stop
contradicting him. That's what I want to
know.
>> Okay. So, he doesn't understand the
context. I think he's mentioned this
too. I better address it. He says that
Allah is asked, okay, to ask the people
of the book, okay, and he's saying that
Allah is confirming from them.
>> Okay. Now, what we know is that the Jews
came and asked the prophet peace and
blessing be upon him. Earlier, remember
I asked him to provide a context. He did
not provide a context. The context was
the Jews wanted to know if there is an
alternative punishment to adultery. So
they came to the prophet peace and
blessings be upon him and they asked
hold on I got I replace the battery.
>> Um I got the camera back.
>> Our batteries are running strong.
>> We don't need to change our batteries.
>> We don't need the Holy Ghost. Okay. our
back strong and it's something none of
us
is not a god
>> our holy ghost we don't need the holy
ghost okay this is what okay so now what
>> okay I want everybody to get y
>> are you done or not he'll tell us when
>> you guys trying to step back
>> yeah but let's step back
>> you ready
>> okay good So let's discuss the term
Muhammad which is in the Quran. Now the
Muhammad means like you said guardian.
There's another word which is a
corrector and there's another
meaning as well is supervisor. What does
it supervise? It did not come to God the
previous scriptures. Notice one thing.
Allah in the Quran is a guardian of the
Quran. Nowhere in the Bible you'll find
that the Bible gospel that God says he's
going to maintain it. He's going to
preserve it until the end of time. Not
once. Even the message that was given by
Jesus and Moses was for a particular
people definitely not the Gentiles. He
says here, "O Israel." Yes, your Lord
God is one. And this is something which
is mentioning very clearly and
addressing only one particular tribe,
the BI is the children of Israel. So we
know that these messages, the previous
messages before the Quran, they were for
a pe particular people. Like even when
Jesus when the woman the side of woman
comes to him and he asks she asked to
help her daughter and he says I do not
give the bread of the children to the
dogs who are the dogs here you guys the
Gentiles not the Jews the Jews are
referred to as the children and their
bread cannot be taken and given to the
dogs the Gentiles so we know that
Jesus's message was primarily for the
ban Israel the message of Moses was also
primarily for the banel whereas the
Quran is a universal message the
universal message of the Quran and hence
Allah in the Quran in chap in uh in in
the Quran Allah says he is the one who's
going to preserve it. It is a book which
was revealed by Allah and he's the one
who's going to preserve it. Very clear
in the Quran. What does Allah show as an
example of preservation today?
>> Today the only book which has been mass
memorized not only mass translated the
Bible the only one that has been mass
memorized is the Quran. Okay. Most
likely the Huff's version because the
>> sorry the H the HS
>> the H.
>> No, you was right. Hey, that's a protein
slip. The H version. You're right.
>> Yeah. version but they started different
versions or different tatas of the
Quran. We don't believe the Quran has
versions. So if we clearly know that the
Quran is the one which has been mass
memorized by millions of people. Okay.
Have you guys memorized any chapter? Any
Christian here memorize even one
chapter? Come here. Come here. Come
here. Read it. Read it. Read it on. No,
no. Of the Bible. Oh, even the Christian
is known as Quran. Alhamdulillah.
>> So, not a single Christian. Yeah. Not
the not even the so-called ex-Christian
or ex-Muslim, whatever you call himself.
Even he memorized. None of your priest
memorized even one chapter of your
Bible. That's that speaks volume. So, we
know that the Quran is being preserved
by Allah in this way. It is uh even most
of the people who memorize the Quran are
actually non-Arabs. The non-Arabs are
the ones who memorize the Quran more
because they're more in number. The
Arabs are like 20%, non-Arabs are more
more than like 80 they're like 80%. So
we know that the Quran has been
preserved both in orally and also as
manuscript we have the from the first
century hijra the manuscripts. So we
know very clearly. Yeah. Going back to
the context of that
why is the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam been asked to confirm with the
people of the scripture is because there
is a particular reason the Jews came to
him. They wanted to know if there's an
alternate punishment for what? For
adultery. And Allah says to them why are
they coming to you when they have it
preserved in the book.
>> What is the punishment preserved in the
book?
>> So they have the Torah.
>> Stop talking. They like I said general
>> generally we believe that the Torah and
it I never denied it. So stop playing
that game with me. So we know that this
particular verse which is in the Torah
that for adultery the punishment even
today you'll find it in the Old
Testament. The punishment was what?
Stoning to death. We find that for there
are many reasons they get stoned to
death. One of them is basically if you
find a woman and listen to the women the
women's take note when you find when
they find you you are not a virgin they
can punish you by stoning you to that in
the old testament which is from the same
god as yours which is trinity
>> according to you. So we have yes the
Muhammad is clear that it preserves what
the true message which Allah wanted to
preserve
>> and this is what he preserved and we see
this throughout the throughout the
history of Islam. We never
all right. So in regarding Muhamm he was
uh you were incorrect about some things.
This is what Alabari says. Now this
Alabari is huge in Sunni Islam. This is
what he says regarding Muahan. Allah
says that he brought down the book the
Quran to you Muhammad believing in the
books that came before it and a witness
to them that they are truth from Allah
to them and protector to them. The root
ha means to protect and watch over them.
That is why it is said when a man
watches over something and protects it,
he has hima over it. Um this the present
form of the verb yohimman and the noun
hina based on what we have mentioned I
know excuse my pronunciation. The people
of interpretation have deferred in their
explanation of the word. For some said
that it means to be a witness. Not a
corrector, not a criterion. It's a
guardian, a witness to the scriptures.
So, and this is why it says even in that
same verse, it says to each of you we
prescribed your own law.
>> Yes,
>> it said it in the same verse
>> that to all of you guys have your own
law. So, if you have your own law, the
Quran is not a criterion over the
previous law.
>> They're all the same except 1094, which
he didn't touch on, says if you're
doubting the Quran, where do you go
>> to the Bible?
>> Have you landed?
>> No. Chad, man, you talked for like 10
minutes, bro. Relax. 10 minutes.
>> Yeah, man. You talk for a whole long, so
relax, man.
>> By the way, can we finish after this and
talk about the Trinity Church? I think
we're done, right?
>> That's fine. That's fine. So, and with
that being said, so since 1094 says that
it demonstrates that the Bible according
to the Quran is the criterion over the
over the Quran, whatever does not line
up with the Bible, that determines that
the Quran is false.
>> And which is why, let me show you, if
you're doubt about what we have
revealed, then go and ask those who've
been reading the scripture before you.
Right? So if Muhammad goes and checks
the Bible and the Quran lines up with
it, he'll know the Quran is good. If it
doesn't line up, he'll know the Quran is
false. So what's the judge? The Bible.
It's as simple as that. 1 plus one
equals two. All right. So with this
being said, he now it was as simple as
the tongue, but he admitted it too that
when it talks about the Qurans that the
best version that is probably most
memorized is the HS version.
>> This one.
>> Let's go to the Bible.
[Music]
Hey, so let me land.
>> We can play the little game.
>> But the part is
>> Guys, let us land. Let us land. Let me
land. I didn't land. I didn't land.
>> No, no, wait, wait, wait. You You had
your turn. I didn't land. You said,
"Let's talk to the Trinity." You said it
was on camera.
>> I said after after you said you said,
"Let's talk about the Trinity."
>> Yeah, after this.
>> By the way, which Bible do you believe
in? The Catholic one or the Protestant?
land.
>> Catholic or Protestant?
>> Both are good. Huh? Both are good.
>> You believe in extra books? Both are
good. Extra books. Both are good. Do you
believe in extra books?
>> Are you okay? Both are good.
>> Question. Do you believe?
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Both are good. Both are good.
>> Both are good. Anyone answer that? Look
at them. Look at that. The Catholic
books have six.
>> Can I Can I land now?
>> Anyone answer that?
>> Can I land? I just answer 30 seconds.
All right. Thank you. Oh, no. It's not
30 seconds. It's not 30 seconds. You are
doing your dance. So now and so now
watch this. And you realize the Bibles
have canonizes. That's all part of it.
So now that we've different books,
>> I got you. We've established that we
have multiple versions of the Quran.
We've established that. So now he lied.
Now you were dishonest. You were
dishonest when you said that I did not
provide the context of 543 about the
judgment, right? When about adultery. I
literally quoted the hadith. No.
>> Yes, I did. I literally I literally said
that they came to about a No. No. Not
just No, not only.
>> Why did you make one? I'll tell you why
it's not only because according to the
Quran, it doesn't say uh uh judge uh uh
I I'm confirming just this law. Just
this law. It says it says bring the
Torah.
>> Bring the Torah with regard to that.
Hold on. Let me finish. Let me finish.
>> Okay.
>> Bring in the Torah. So whatever the
Torah says on it that that was law
because it's a revelation from God. So
the entire Torah is confirmed by
Muhammad. So
>> guys, all in all, here's a summary.
Here's a summary. You say arrogance.
Okay, we'll go with that.
>> Here's a When I ask Jill, he says, "We
don't need to know what it is."
>> When I ask who wrote it, he says, "We
don't know who wrote it."
>> When I ask when was it written, he says,
"We don't need to know who it's
written." So from now on, Hashem Hey, I
got you. From from now on, Yeah. Yeah.
The
>> And guess what? The Torah The Torah The
Torah according to the Quran is the
criteria.
>> The criteria. You keep it. You going to
keep it?
>> Yeah. Because you should learn now.
>> Okay. You All right. I'm doing the same
to you. I'll do the same to you.
>> So now let's talk about the trinity. I'm
not done. I'm not done.
>> What do you mean you're not done?
>> Dude, you got to let me learn my point,
bro.
>> How long did it take?
>> If you interrupt me, it takes longer.
>> No, if you dance,
give me a minute.
>> Okay, go on.
>> Okay, so we already established he has
no answer to what the angel is. We saw
him go against the Quran when it says
you can't pick and choose what you
believe in. But you're saying, "Yeah, we
can pick and choose what's confirmed."
>> The Quran.
>> So guess what? I'll grant his position
on 279. I don't agree, but let's sing.
Let's just say the Quran says that it's
been corrupted. So that means that Allah
is confirming corrupted books.
>> Bye-bye by Islam. There's Hey, this is
the Islamic dilemma. It hasn't been a
minute, dude. You haven't count.
>> Either Hey, look. Either either the
either the scriptures are corrupted.
Either the scriptures are corrupted and
the Quran is false for confirming
>> or the scriptures are preserved. Come
on, dude. Are you okay?
>> I am okay. But you should you're in
panic mode, bro.
>> It's been a minute. You're in panic
mode. Now, the reason he want he want
actually address.
>> So, what we have is is we have in our
mission that we don't know what the is.
So, the question still is
the
angel.
>> Revelation.
>> Revelation. Oh my jail.
[Music]
Oh my god.
Heat. Hey, heat. Hey, heat.